i mean 90 senators in washington don't
agree on anything
but they did on the usnbc
[Music]
actually voted against the usmca because
she said it didn't go far enough on
climate change
but you all deserve to know here in
michigan that joe biden
put her radical environmental agenda
ahead of michigan jobs and michigan auto
workers
[Music]
but i promise you under president donald
trump
we are always going to put american jobs
and american workers first
then you got energy play such an
important role drives prosperity in
michigan all across the heartland
i know you've heard of joe biden and
colin harris over the last
year have repeatedly said
that they want to ban fracking and
abolish
possible fuels
and joe biden actually said in the
presidential debate the other night
and how good was president trump
and they start talking
i mean the president
you know i mean according to a 2017
study by a non-political group
the oil and gas industry supports 160
000
jobs right here in michigan
and they want they're talking about
whatever they're saying right now
it's like you know honestly joe biden
[Applause]
but president donald trump has been a
champion for american
energy and american energy independence
[Music]
we've developed all the resources of our
land and america
is a net exporter of energy for the
first time in
70 years
[Applause]
you know when it comes to jobs and trade
and energy president trump will always
put
michigan and america
on this economy you know honestly six
days to go to michigan we got a choice
to make
this state will play an outside role
[Applause]
[Music]
election president says it all
when you look at our agenda of less
taxes
less regulations free and fair trade
american energy independence you look at
here more taxes more
regulation economic surrender on
trade less american energy it's clear
this election is a choice between a
trump recovery
and abiding
[Music]
economic policies would cost 5 million
american jobs
and the average american family would
lose 6
500 a year in income so
in all the six days i want you to reach
out to neighbors and friends here in
clinton all across
the state i want you
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
a career politician with 47 years
washington raising taxes stifling the
economy waving a white
flag of economic surrender on trade
or a proven job creator that'll keep
cutting taxes fighting for american jobs
and american workers
for a great american comeback in
michigan
and across this nation we need four
more years of president donald trump in
the white house
[Applause]
[Music]
so it's about our security it's about
our
who stands every day with the men and
women who serve on the thin blue line of
law enforcement
[Applause]
president trump and i know but you know
many women have put on the uniform of
law enforcement
[Music]
[Applause]
the right of peaceful protest is
enshrined in our constitution
but writing and looting like we saw last
night in philadelphia
[Music]
it's not peaceful protest starting
businesses
is not free speech
for months remember all summer long all
joe
talked about was peaceful protesters
right
never condemning people that were
literally burning
businesses to the ground i was in
[Music]
in minneapolis 35 years ago
built it up with her sister told me the
other day
a couple days after the killing of
george
saw the violent protesters coming closer
and closer
and closer to the ground
you know the truth is joe biden would
double down on the policies that have
led i mean when you
refuse to condemn
those that perpetrate violence against
our families and our communities when
you
when you start to withdraw support from
those who protect
and serve you only embolden us
we're tearing our communities
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
for four more years
you know you and i know the president
knows we don't have to choose between
supporting
law enforcement and supporting our
african-american neighbors and friends
and
other minorities and families that live
in our major cities
i mean for the last three and a half
years we've come home
and we'll keep doing both
when foreign was taken over in major
cities this summer we launched operation
legend
and we've arrested more than 2 500
violent offenders working with local law
[Music]
[Applause]
and at the enforcement same time i
couldn't be more proud
that under our administration we saw the
lowest unemployment ever recorded for
african americans
the highest funding for historically
black colleges
and universities we supported
educational choice for families
and 8 000 opportunity zones
that are creating jobs in inner cities
including the opportunity zone right
here in flint michigan
we're going to support law enforcement
we're going to support our minority
communities
and we're going to have law and order in
every city
in every state in america for every
one of us race and clean and color so
help us god
[Applause]
in support of the rule of law i'm proud
to report
all the great michigan
we stand here today president trump has
actually
appointed more than 220 conservatives
and they are all men and women who will
uphold the god-given liberties enshrined
in our constitution
like the freedom of religion the freedom
of speech
and the second amendment
federal vets three supreme court
[Music]
[Applause]
justice league justice brett kavanaugh
and
justice amy coney barrett
this is great
[Applause]
[Music]
an incredible person who just happens to
be from indiana
[Applause]
[Music]
we think it's all the other way she now
occupies the seat of late justice
through peter pinsburg
and the truth is justice kinsburg was a
trailblazer for women
women in the lawn this country inspired
generations of women to step forward
the incredible character and life story
and
serious prudence of justice
[Applause]
[Music]
one of those young
she just women from law school she is
part of that rising generation
of young incredible man who's going to
do great things
my daughter audrey pence everybody
you know when you think about the parks
and all that we've been able to
accomplish
it's been because of the strong support
we got from the people of michigan it's
been because you have a
and it's one more reason why we need to
send
john james to a renewed republican
majority in the united states
the last administration actually hauled
a group of nuns into the federal court
to force them to compromise their faith
and live under the mandate
the catchphrase
the leading democrat on the judiciary
committee
expressed the same religious intolerance
that it was seen from so many
she said she was concerned about judge
because of her devout catholic faith
she said and i quote the dogma
is loudly within you
and hollywood elise started attacking
the judge
well i got a message from the democrats
in washington and their friends in
hollywood
that dogma lives loudly in me
and the right to live and work and
worship according to the dictates of our
faith
lives loudly in the constitution of the
united states
of america
[Music]
under president trump we've not only
appointed men and women to our courts
who have hold our religious freedom but
we restored the conscious rights of
doctors and nurses
religious charities and organizations it
was president donald trump
who ended the legal assault on the
little sisters
of the poor and the supreme court made
it permanent
president donald trump has stood for the
freedom of religion of
every american of every faith and we're
going to do it for four
more years
[Music]
[Applause]
and finally we're joe biden
support taxpayer funding of abortion all
the way up to the moment of birth
i couldn't be more proud to serve
alongside a president
who stands without apology for the
sanctity of human life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's an amazing first year because of
the support of the people of michigan in
2016.
we rebuilt our military we revived our
economy we stood for law and order of
liberty
and none of that would have been
possible without strong and consistent
support
of michigan's republican delegation of
congress
so you're going to favor that right
after you re-elect president donald
trump
and send john james to the united states
senate
[Music]
we need you to send congressman john
hollander to a new republican majority
in the house of representatives and
retire
nancy pelosi once
[Music]
[Music]
oh
we made america great again
[Music]
[Applause]
and then 2020 arrived
in the ground up
before the very first case
of a community transmission anywhere in
america president trump did what no
american had ever done in the history of
this country
he suspended all travel from china the
second largest economy in the world
president trump with the health of
america first
[Applause]
now joe biden joe biden said it was
xenophobic
literally wrote a few days before the
president's action that
banning travel during the global
pandemic would make things worse
you got it wrong president trump got it
wrong
the greatest national since world war
ii we reinvented testing we thought of
the manufacturer all across the
heartland
of billions of supplies of personal
protective equipment
ventilators
therapeutics that are saving lives today
and before the end of this year
we believe we will have tens of millions
of doses of the first coronavirus
vaccine in the world
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i must tell you until that day comes
that we put this pandemic in the past
the safe and effective vaccine we're
going to keep moving heaven
to make sure that our doctors and nurses
all across the country have the
resources
and the support they need to give anyone
in this struggle
and in this manner they make the level
of health care we want a family member
[Music]
we are opening up america again
[Applause]
i mean it's amazing to think amazing to
think on that foundation that the
president covered those first three
years
and with the unprecedented support
congressman john mulliner
helped to provide direct payments to the
families
direct payments to businesses to keep
nearly 50
million americans on the payroll small
businesses after we lost 22 million jobs
at the height of this pandemic
we've already seen eleven and a half
million people
go back to work in the last five months
including
600 000 people right here in michigan
we are opening up america again
so we've gone through a time of testing
i know you came out on this cold night
because you know
six days from now we're coming to a time
for choosing
the choice of this election
higher taxes open borders socialized
medicine
a green new deal
we love you
[Music]
she was more liberal than bernie sanders
in the last year now joe biden says that
democracy is on the ballot
i think our economic recovery is on the
back
i think law and order are on the
[Applause]
ends up battlefield democrat or more
republican
more liberal and more conservative more
red and more blue
i think choice in this election is
whether america remains mayor
it's whether we're going to start of
course for our children and our
grandchildren
with a renewed commitment to freedom
patriotism
[Applause]
[Music]
and the radical left turn
our nation toward an inevitable
so for our freedom and for all the
ideals that have always made america
great
michigan we need to decide right here
and right now
that joe biden will never be president
of the united states we're going to
re-elect president donald trump
for four more years
you know uh four years ago when the
president called me
asked me to join this ticket i said yes
in a heartbeat
because i knew the time that we spent
together
i knew he had a vision
[Music]
some people think we're a little bit
different
but we've gotten to be very close
friends
we're at the white house we're together
for hours a day over the last three and
a half years
when we travel in different places we
speak every day just like we did this
morning
now let me tell you the first thing
i've seen our president when the cameras
are off
[Music]
resistance in opposition by the
democrats in washington
against unfair and unrelenting
attacks by their allies in the national
media
there has never been a day going
but i haven't seen this president get up
and
fight to keep the promises that he made
for the people
of michigan now it's our turn to fight
for him
[Music]
so i got a few things i gotta ask you to
do you know i got a plane to catch
[Music]
so first we have the president
i want to ask we need you to
vote michigan vote to re-elect
president donald trump
[Applause]
you take advantage of that early voting
my wife and i just voted down in
indianapolis a couple days ago
the president did that you need to
open85 c201c
[Music]
[Applause]
and remember friends don't let friends
vote alone
bring a member neighbor
a friend and vote to re-elect president
donald trump to the lighthouse
[Applause]
just get it done let's get it done come
on
first thing secondly second
after you vote with a friend
i want you to go
actions ever in the life of this nation
it really is a moment where we're going
to decide for our children and our
grandchildren
not just who will be in the white house
the other night
[Music]
she said how would you describe your
supporters
and he said they are people who love
our country
[Applause]
[Music]
that we have a president who loves this
country
and who's going to continue to fight to
put america first
well i asked you to do that because i
really do believe
history making election in 2016 here in
michigan
all across the country
which is pretty positive
social media the most powerful media in
this country
is some of the american
and people someone who knows you and
respects you hears from you
about an issue that's important i'm just
saying to you when we have the war
talks on behalf of the congressman on
behalf of the president
take some time to reach out to your
neighbors and friends
just come back out of the airport
for like an hour just trying to
summarize everything we've done
the choice that we face and what we're
gonna do
to make this country great again for
four more years with president donald
trump
in the white house
and lastly
over the last four years
[Music]
and this is a nation of faith
[Music]
i mean everywhere the president
[Applause]
[Music]
and so if you're inclined to bow the
head and bend the knee from time to time
through much more challenging times than
even we could possibly imagine
that if his people who are called by his
name will humble themselves and pray
and turn that he'll do like he's always
done
in a long restored history of this great
nation
[Applause]
with liberty and justice for all
so pray for america pray for all the
american people
it'll make a difference
with that i'm going to let you get back
somewhere warm tonight but i just want
[Music]
[Applause]
i leave here today with renewed
confidence
all of us do all that we need to do
over the next six days all across the
great state of michigan all across
america
we're gonna have a great victory
it was john james
in a renewed republican majority in the
united states senate
with congressman john molinar in a new
republican majority
the president donald trump in the white
house
[Music]
[Applause]
and with gods
i tell you i just know right
we will make america great again again
[Music]
thank you all very much god bless you
god bless america now let's go get it
done michigan
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
what do feel
[Music]
[Music]
feet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
oh very good
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you